okay so the topic of this video is
ecology and the ecological levels of
organization so let's go ahead and get
started well let's go ahead and start by
just defining what is ecology and it's
the study of how life interacts within
one's environment you know here's a
picture of a food web and this food web
shows how light interacts by
transferring nutrients from one organism
to another as organisms feed upon each
other and so this is a great example of
what we've learned by studying ecology
is how energy moves throughout the
ecosystem for instance and so the whole
point of ecology is really to show the
impact that life has on the environment
and vice versa
you know this picture here shows that
over the past few decades the amount of
coal natural gas and liquid fuels oils
have increased and therefore we've gone
off more and more carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere and this has an impact on
the quality of life well you know what
I'd like you to do really quick is think
about how do you positively interact
with in the environment maybe you're
into rock climbing you know maybe you're
more into surfing maybe you're you enjoy
going on nature hikes
maybe horseback riding maybe fishing but
there are ways in which we all interact
positively within the environment I'm
asking you if you can take a moment to
kind of contemplate and reflect on ways
that you interact within your
environment
well you know let's actually get into
the ecological levels of organization
here starting with a population a group
of the same species living in the area
and you know before we go on and and
talk more about populations let's just
have a little bit of fun here we have a
group of fish you know what's the word
that we would call a group of fish well
that would be a school well how about
this one a blank of sheep what word is
missing this would be a herd don't worry
they get harder okay how about this one
blank of kittens well that would be a
litter how about this one blank of geese
they're gonna start think a little bit
more challenging you know this would be
a gaggle of geese how about this one a
blank of lions that would be a pride a
blank of monkeys that would be a troop a
blank of whales well that would be a pod
a blank of jellyfish oh that would be a
smack of jellyfish and kind of my
favorite one blank of crows that would
be a murder a murder of crows no no I'm
if you're in my biology class I'm not
going to test you on all of those that
was just a living a little fun and be a
little silly let's get back though to
populations and kind of studying in the
patterns that we've learned so here's a
group of rabbits here now eventually
these rabbits are going to multiply
they're gonna reproduce make offspring
and and throughout the generations their
numbers will probably accumulate now
there are what we call limiting factors
within the environment that keep the
population of rabbits under control you
know probably one of the most obvious
limiting factors would be predation the
fact that predators help to control the
population of prey simply by catching
and eating them so if there's wolves are
lurking around they would probably catch
and and keep the rabbit population under
control another example would be
competition competition for food
competition for territory
lack of resources you know water could
be a lack of could be as a very
important resource and if there's not
enough of it in this particular
environment then that would control the
populations as would disease as more
individuals are born the chance of
spreading disease is greater so these
are called limiting factors and when we
start to graph a population we notice
the populations tend to go through
stages so here's a graph of a typical
population growth pattern and we can
actually break it down into three stages
what we notice first is a slow growth
period the population is growing slowly
as it's adapting to its particular
environment so over time if I plot these
points here yeah you can see the plot
points are going up a little bit but
it's a very slow growth and then you
start thinking well why is that well at
this time birth rates are probably
pretty low the the life that is growing
here that they're struggling to survive
you know natural selection is is slowly
eliminating those that are not to
survive in this environment and those
that are fit to survive will eventually
start to reproduce and make lots of
offspring and that kind of leads us into
stage two mo stage two is a period of
what is called exponential growth
notice how the plot points suddenly
dramatically sharply increase high birth
rates due to natural selection and
resources at this point the weaker
individuals within the population within
the herd perhaps have been eliminated by
perhaps predators and so you have the
very best adapted males and the very
best adapted females breeding and
reproducing with one another to make
very well adapted offspring and so at
this time we experienced a population
surge called exponential growth
and that leads us to stage three when
the population tends to hit a plateau it
starts to level off at a period known as
its carrying capacity this is the
greatest number of individuals that the
environment can sustain there's just
maybe not enough food for for many more
individuals within this particular
environment and so if we kind of connect
the dots here and you can see this nice
little what is called an s-shaped growth
pattern use your imagination you can
kind of see the letter S in that curve
right there of the line and this is
fairly typical across populations you
know when I look at this graph right
here which shows the total human
population throughout time ask yourself
what stage of population growth are
humans within well you can see we're in
the exponential growth stage the line is
curving upward at a very high rate and
so you think but why is that why are we
in exponential growth well today we're
pretty good at fighting disease or mass
producing more and more food we're
building shelters in environments that
used to be inhospitable were irrigating
in the middle of deserts and so we're
bringing water to environments that
don't typically have water and so by
doing all this we're able to to produce
more and more resources to support more
and more of humans and so what happens
once carrying capacity is reached
reached well let me extend let me extend
my graph a little bit well there's two
patterns that we tend to see next number
one the population tends to stabilize
and that's what we hope will eventually
happen to humans eventually we would
have predict predict the human
population to reach a carrying capacity
we hope it will stabilize now the other
possibility is this well the other
possibility is this here if I plot the
data points what is called a population
crash so which of these is eventually in
store for humans will humans stabilize
after reaching carrying capacity or will
the human population experience
well we just don't know hopefully we can
take the lessons from ecology and other
areas of society and other areas of
culture to to prevent this population
crash well let's flip the page here and
talk about what are called communities a
community are many populations living in
the same area here we have our rabbits
and let's also include you know plant
life grasses and trees and maybe even in
some fun fungus mushrooms growing here
and some birds have maybe migrated into
this area and lurking in the background
our wolves that keep the rabbit
population under control this would be
an example of a community well
throughout nature there's all kinds of
communities you know here's a desert
community aside from the vegetation you
see I'm sure there's insects scurrying
around and reptiles and you know perhaps
even small mammals make up part of the
desert community here's a coral reef
community you know you have the corals
themselves which are alive Plus maybe
invertebrates like you know shrimp and
crabs and don't forget about the
vertebrate fish that are swimming around
I'll make up the coral reef community
and even in a wetland community here you
have of course the the plant life that
you see in the picture but also the fish
that are swimming around birds that
migrate in insects you know these are
all part of the wetland community and so
the patterns from studying communities
well each organism has its own habitat
habitat is simply the place where an
organism lives here we see you know
there's a den here which is used as a
habitat a place to live you know here's
an example of a bird building a nest is
part of its habitat
here's a Oh a wasp nest if I remember
correctly and again part of the habitat
where these wasps would then live and
even in the aquatic organisms as well
here we have some clownfish burrowing
amongst the tentacles of an anemone
and also another pattern is that every
species tends to have its own niche well
you know if you're watching this video
and you're probably a high school
student and I hope that you find your
niche within your school maybe your
niches may be a part of the the
Performing Arts maybe your niches may be
more towards athletics maybe your niche
is just with a group of like-minded
classmates and friends that you've
accumulated over the years I hope you
see what a niche is it's kind of where
you fit in to your school and if we
apply this word niche to biology it's
the role of a species the needs of a
species for instance rabbits would be a
good example part of their niche would
be that they're herbivores they help
control the plant population and then
the Predators the wolves are predators
and carnivores they help to control the
population of let's say the rabbits
well the mushrooms are decomposers they
break down dead plant material dead
animal material and return nutrients to
the soil so the plants can then grow
even better and so these are examples of
the niche that the organisms have in
their community we look at those birds
you know not only are the birds maybe
omnivores because maybe they eat insects
and also berries but part of their niche
is also perhaps the blue ones will nest
build their nest and lay their eggs in
the autumn and they eat insect and
living in the exact same trees might be
these other birds and you would think
they'd compete with one another wouldn't
the blue birds chase away the white bird
excuse me the blue birds chase away the
pink birds or maybe the pink birds would
chase away the blue birds well what
prevents that is they each have their
own niche maybe the pink birds build
their nest in the springtime and they
eat a different kind of insects so even
though they're living in the same
habitat they're living in the same trees
their niche they have a separate niche
where they don't overlap and therefore
they're able to coexist
let's flip the page to the next higher
level called an eco system and this is
not just the living but also the
nonliving parts of an of an environment
here we have everything that we've seen
before but let me add some rocks and let
me add a pond and let me add some
moisture in the sky in the in form of
clouds and let's add the sun shining on
a nice sunny day this would now be more
symbolic here of an ecosystem an
ecosystem is made of the living parts or
the biotic factors within in the
environment the animals the plants the
fungus the bacteria the Protista in my
collage in my collage everything that's
blinking right now is part of the living
part of the biotic conditions of this
particular ecosystem well then there's
also the nonliving factors or the
abiotic aspects of an ecosystem these
are the rocks the climate the soil the
water factors that can influence life
but are not alive themselves in my
pelage you can see the water is blinking
the clouds the Sun the rocks the soil
these are all part of the nonliving
components with them within an ecosystem
and so the patterns from study and
ecosystems well this sounds very
scientific it's actually pretty
straightforward though biotic is
affected by the abiotic again it sounds
really fancy but all we're saying is
that life can be affected by nonliving
factors for instance here we have a
picture of some of a drought in a dry
area and it says the success of plants
and animals is greatly impacted by
drought nonliving factors such as a lack
of water can greatly impact things that
are alive another example would be what
we see in this picture right here the
aquatic organisms that live in this
water weigh the fish for instance maybe
some amphibians they would be harmed by
any of the chemicals that are in the
pollution given off by this factory here
and so chemicals and pollution those are
abiotic
nonliving factors but they can have a
big impact on the quality of life and
here we have an example of what's called
coral bleaching if you're familiar with
this this is really sad the destruction
of coral reefs coral reefs are living
organisms but their health is incredibly
threatened because of rising ocean
temperatures and temperature and water
these are this is a biotic waters not
alive temperature is not a living factor
but these are nonliving factors that can
greatly influence the health of things
in our life and the other pattern is
really does vice-versa this sounds very
complicated here abiotic is affected by
the biotic but what it really says is
that things that are not alive can be in
can be impacted by things at our life
for instance
the nutrient quality of soil is greatly
aided by the actions of for instance
fungus fungus our living organisms but
they return nutrients into the soil and
soil is a nonliving abiotic component of
an ecosystem and another example would
be climate change Earth's climate is a
nonliving factor but it's being altered
by the actions of humans when we are
very much part of the biotic world well
throughout ecology we've identified what
are called keystone species and these
are ones that have an unusually large
impact within their ecosystem you know
humans are an obvious example let's look
at a couple less of these examples for
instance beavers are a good example of a
keystone species they have an unusually
large impact on their ecosystem by them
creating beaver dams they will slow the
flow of this little stream here and that
creates pools of water which are our
habitats for greater numbers of fish of
course the increased fish might attract
birds to the area to build their nest
and live out their lives to hunt the
fish and then the still water created
because of the Beaver Dam is a breeding
ground for insects so by removing the
Beavers and the beaver dam
this entire ecosystem might not even
exist and that's what we mean by a
keystone species they have a great
impact on their and their ecosystem
another example of a keystone species
would be sea otters they're adorably
cute but they're also really wonderful
in maintaining the quality of kelp
forests and so sea otters help to
control the population of sea urchins
that scurry along the bottom of the
ocean and sea urchins can be devastating
to kelp forests because the urchins will
eat away at the base of the kelp break
the stalk of kelp and it kind of floats
away with the current of the ocean and
so to prevent that and to help maintain
the health of the kelp forests you know
the the sea otters will eat the urchins
now the problem we're seeing in though
is of course that sea otters are
threatened due to overhunting
and due to habitat loss and so these
very healthy kelp forests are actually
becoming threatened because the urchins
are over populating and destroying these
beautiful kelp forests so but that's an
example of a keystone species how the
actions of one species the actions of
the sea otters can have a huge impact on
their ecosystem
okay let's flip and go to a biome a
large area with a very distinct climate
plant life in animal life
so let's zoom out here's my collage of
an ecosystem from a moment to go let the
zoom out and when we zoom out even
further we come to an example of a biome
here notice how what I mean by a large
area of land covers in this case
northern United States and Canada and so
this is an example of the taiga biome
this biome is characteristic of having
moderately warm summers long cold dry
winters another example would be deserts
the desert biome you can see some desert
locations from this map and desert
characteristics a general
characteristics here they tend to be
warm throughout the year very hot in the
summer and dry another example of a
biome would be the tundra the tundra
characterized by extremely low
temperatures little precipitation poor
nutrients and very short growing seasons
another example of a biome would be the
rainforest tropical rainforests
typically along the equator of the earth
these are warm year-round these biomes
have warm year-round temperatures with a
lot of rainfall and the greatest
diversity of species anywhere on earth
another example of a biome would be
deciduous forests and these are
characterized by well to have and
well-defined seasons their trees tend to
lose their leaves in the autumn and as a
result this soil is very rich in
nutrients because all those decaying
leaves add to the nutrient and the
nutrient richness of the soil well how
about the grasslands grasslands you can
see here in this particular and these
are lands like the name implies
dominated by grasses you tend to have
hot summers and cold winters rainfall
tends to be moderate not enough rain to
get big trees but you know tall grasses
and such and so the pattern is that the
climate of a biome really determines
what life can survive you know here's
kind of a map of
biomes of the world you know there's a
reason we find cacti and let's say
Southwest desert United States here is
because the climate of this particular
biome supports their growth there's a
reason we see polar bears in you know
northern Canada in this area of the
world because they are adapted to the
climate of this particular biome and
here in northern Australia for instance
saltwater saltwater crocodiles provides
the perfect environment the climate is
suitable for their survival and maybe
along the equator like perhaps in Costa
Rica is where we find you know slots
right here again the climate of this
biome supports their ability to survive
these are these four organisms would
probably do very poorly if they were to
be transported to other biomes around
the world to survive and fend for
themselves
okay let's flip the page and talk about
the final ecological level the biosphere
and this is really the area of the earth
where life can be found you know when I
look at this picture here of the earth
is the core of the earth a part of the
biosphere and the answer is no not at
all is the mantle a part of the
biosphere no there's no life as far as
we can tell in the mantle and in the
core how about the entire crust is the
entire crust a part of the biosphere
no so again it's not the earth the
entire earth it's a part of the
biosphere
it's the portion of the earth where we
can find life and I think this picture
really shows nicely where the biosphere
is well at its highest point about 12
kilometers above sea level
is this particular vulture right here
which has been identified as being the
world's highest flying animal hives
flying bird and at the lowest point
about 11 kilometers below sea level are
these little microscopic organisms
called for a manoeuvre and if you google
the phrase benthic foraminifera you can
read more about these and so everything
in between that vulture on top and the
microscopic foraminifera at the bottom
of the picture that's the biosphere
now the vulture represents the extreme
upper part of the biosphere and the
Femina furrow represent extreme lower
part of the biosphere but most life is
found within this red region here about
6000 metres above sea level and about
500 metres below sea level that's where
we find most life within the biosphere
and so the pattern is that the biosphere
changes any changes to the biosphere can
have a tremendous impact on life you
know you probably know our atmosphere
has some carbon dioxide in it and energy
from the Sun will radiate across space
and the carbon dioxide as well as other
greenhouse gases like methane carbon
dioxide being these greenhouse gases
tend to absorb some of the heat and keep
our planet nice and warm
we call this the greenhouse effect and
the greenhouse effect is viewed as a
very good quality helps to naturally
warm our planet but what we've seen is
over the past few decades is the input
and the release of a lot more carbon
dioxide and other greenhouse gases into
the atmosphere and as a result this
tends to trap more and overly warm the
planet and this is what is known as
climate change here so one of the
patterns is that greatly impacting by
altering the biosphere can have a great
impact on life
well as I wrap up this video I want to
mention three scientists that were very
inspirational throughout my childhood
one being Carl Sagan to being Jacque
Cousteau and the third being Jane
Goodall you know when I was a child
growing up these three were regularly
airing you know documentaries on PBS and
I was just fascinated by them and it led
to me wanting to study more and more
science as I got older and each of them
has left an impact throughout ecology
each of them has helped us to understand
the impact that we have in our
environment and in our world and it's
one of the reasons why I think this fits
as part of this presentation and if I
can finish with this the Voyager 1 space
probe if you're familiar with this in
1977 NASA launched the Voyager 1 and
Voyager 2 probes to explore the solar
system and in 1990 this picture right
here was taken by Voyager 1 and this
picture has been titled the pale blue
dot past Neptune at a distance of about
6 billion kilometres from Earth
Voyager 1 took a photograph of Earth you
can see that little tiny blue pixel
right there that's the planet Earth at
an incredibly far distance and in his
book Carl Sagan wrote a venn book titled
pale blue dot and I'm not gonna read
this for you if you're interested pause
the video and and and please read
yourself but I found these words just to
be inspirational and just to reflect
upon the impact that I have and my
relationship with the environment that I
grew up within and so there you have it
if you're in my biology class going
pause the video and try to answer these
questions I'm happy to check your
answers before or after school one day
and and if you have any comments you
know post them below I'd like to see
what you think thanks for watching